you
[Music]
okay we'll get going it's an honor to
have
unka again here with us today she's an
assistant professor in ECS that UC
Berkeley
she's been working on enabling robots to
work with I love the sentence work with
around and in support of people she
directs the interact lab which focuses
on algorithms for human robot
interaction that move beyond a robot's
function in isolation thinking more
deeply about giving them the ability to
generate behaviors that account for
interaction and coordination with people
so resonates deeply with Microsoft
Research directions and goals the team
in interact lab explores a number of
different applications including
assistive robots
what about to manufacturing autonomous
cars and so on and these technologies
build on Flenory research including
optimal control planning estimation
learning and insights that come from
cognitive psychology and could excuse me
everybody it's unka ANCA helped to fight
to found and serves on the steering
committee for the Brooklyn yeah research
lab bear the bear lab she's a COPI I of
the Center for Human compatible AI she
received the Sloan fellowship
MIT T r35 honor Okawa Award and an NSF
Career Award as many of you know did her
PhD work some with colleagues here in
part at CMU so
always great to be here thanks so much
for having me as Eric said I tend to
focus on the algorithms that are behind
human robot interaction so I figured
we'd start with just a couple of
examples of what human robot interaction
looks like so here's an example and word
from collaboration with Claire Tomlin's
grew up at UC Berkeley we have a human
labeled as human being for clarity and
we have this little quadrotor and they
need to navigate around each other and
not bump into each other that's all and
this you know looks easy but there's
ways to screw even this up so here's a
way to screw it up you make the wrong
predictions about what's gonna happen
and the quadrotor gets in the way of the
person even collides with the person we
don't we want to avoid something like
that here's another example this is
imagine I have this robot and it's doing
some stuff for me and it's right now
moving this mug from one place to
another and as I see it move I feel like
God's keeping this mug too high up so
what do I do well I want to be able to
push on it sort of correct it right to
teach it to keep the mug closer to the
table the concern being that if it drops
it maybe it will break and that's not
good because it's my favorite mug and so
on so I'm also a simple thing ways that
the robot can screw this up again one
way that it can screw this up is by not
actually being compliant to my to my
input and rejecting this external torque
that I'm applying as a disturbance
that's an obvious way a more subtle way
is that okay maybe it's compliant like
it was just now but the moment I let go
it goes back to doing the task in the
exact same way it knows how to do the
task before so I can't have to keep
pushing on in it keeps coming back and I
keep pushing on it and it you know it
feels stubborn um so we want to avoid
also something like that these these
things would be easy if a person were in
the space
a robot we can navigate around each
other if you push me I sort of get what
that means but these human behaviors are
tricky for robots to interpret so
because we haven't really given robots a
manual for how to interpret our
behaviors right we haven't written a
human behavior for dummies manual yet
and in a sense that's what a lot of my
work is about is providing such such an
instruction manual for robots now
formally what happens when you have a
robotics problem is you usually define
some utility function and the robot job
is to find a policy fired that map
states to actions that maximize the
expected utility that's kind of the
definition of the AI problem we've made
some progress towards that the challenge
what's what's challenging and exciting
at the same time about interaction is
that the moment the robot needs to do
this in the same space as a person is
also acting the problem fundamentally
changes at its core and it changes
because at the very least now the robots
utility is no longer just a function of
the robots policy it also depends on the
person's policy and how well these two
policies end up meshing together at the
very least because we don't want the
human and the robot to end up bumping
into each other and usually because we
want them to collaborate well and
coordinate well and so on and so for the
robot to be deciding on what's a good
idea what's a good policy or trajectory
for itself it needs to start reasoning
about the human what they might be doing
and this is a pretty tall order right
you need a model of human behavior and
so this is naturally something that
we're gonna want to involve data with
the question is though how what's the
right way to involve data here in this
kind of day and age um if I were to look
at this problem what naturally would
come to mind is this approach of let's
collect a bunch of data of people acting
and fit some sort of black box policy
to this data so take a high-capacity
neural network and fit it to what we
observe humans doing and this is
appealing for its simplicity but
unfortunately it's not always gonna work
out and the reason is imagine that let's
draw on the slide all possible policies
only some of those are policies that a
real human would ever take the
challenges would have no idea where
these are in the space of all policies
and so the black box approach to the
problem is to cast a very wide net is to
use some class of models high capacity
models and cover our basis and that
sounds appealing because it gives us a
lot of flexibility but what happens is
we end up collecting some amount of data
even a large amount of data and there
are going to be a lot of policies in our
hypothesis space that are consistent
with this data that we collected and so
then what can happen is if we have a
thin kind of any kind of distributional
shift we can be in trouble because
chances are we haven't landed by magic
on that one that happens to be the
correct one and so indeed what can
happen if we plot the robot cumulative
reward as a function of the amount of
human data we expose the robot to is in
some cases we might see that we don't
get that much better with the amount of
human data if the data doesn't come from
the right distribution and if we get on
policy data well that's really helpful
but on policy data can be really
expensive imagine for a human robot
interaction that means you have a robot
that's still learning and it takes
actions and see how people are reacting
to that and that's not something that
you can afford to do in a lot of
applications especially safety-critical
applications and so then the challenge
becomes what hypothesis space should we
be using why what is the space that we
should be searching for a policy over
when we're fitting a model of human
behavior in other words what is the
right
inductive bias to use when it comes to
learning for human robot interaction and
that's really what this talk is about
and that's what question that has
consumed me for the past few years and
I'm not I don't think I know the answer
I think I got a little bit closer to the
answer and so let me share some of the
things that I found out to you today so
to start answering these questions what
we have to think about is well if it's
not arbitrary blackbox policy is what
makes the human behavior what makes us
think that humans are not arbitrary and
to me the key here is that we take
actions not arbitrarily because the
actions that we take are driven by
purposeful decisions that we make now we
have this thing that we use to make
decisions and these decisions are in
support of the stuff we want to achieve
of the intentions that we have right I'm
walking this way because I want to go to
the exit
I am steering this way on my drive home
and pressing the acceleration pedal this
way because I want to get home and I
want to stay on the road and I want to
not crash into things and I want to be
as efficient and I want to be
comfortable and so on that's what I mean
by intentions and so it seemed to me
that it's this notion of people are
people they behave in the way they do
because of their intentions seem
differing like this notion was something
that we really ought to leverage when it
comes to learning in human robot
interaction but the challenge is that
humans have antennas very fuzzy
statements to make and so how do you
take this and turn it into some formal
useful inductive bias for a robot to use
so that's kind of the journey that I
went on and I drew it here as this nice
girl downhill but it was this kind of
treacherous adventure and then we'll get
to dig our heels in a little bit today
so let me start with the starting point
so the starting point for me was almost
like a 180 from the notion of blackboard
policy and it wasn't the answer wasn't
the final answer but it was a key
component of the final answer and that
was I didn't know when I thought about
intent I'd really couldn't figure out
how to formalize intent other than to go
back to essentially economics and say
intent corresponds to some utility some
objective function that the person cares
about optimizing there's something that
they want and I'm gonna capture that via
a utility function and in this talk the
utility function is gonna be
parametrized by some parameters that
we're gonna call theta
each concretely what does this mean well
let me share a couple examples um in
this example where a person is
navigating um theta H might their
intention might represent the actual
goal location the robot doesn't know the
goal location necessarily but it knows
that it's one of some possible locations
in a room and it knows that the person
will try to get close to their goal will
also try to be efficient will try to
avoid obstacles when the person is
driving a car a vehicle we know that
they care about a bunch of things let's
call the youth criterion fee and what we
don't know so these are things like
efficiency and comfort and safety risk
and stuff like that now I don't know how
people combine these criteria so maybe
I'm gonna call the trade-offs that they
make I'm gonna use that to de no my
theta H and that's gonna be the thing
that the robot doesn't know about on
more generally you could think of theta
H is being weights in some neural
network that map's state in action to a
scalar value for how good that is you
just have to be a little bit careful
with that because the whole point here
is that the space of intentions the
space of data HS is supposed to be
smaller than the space of all possible
behaviors and so that's the key right so
we when we go into this one we have to
be a little bit careful about how what
additional assumptions we make and how
we regularize this and again the idea is
that if I know theta each
that's really all I need to know that
theta age should induce the behavior so
that I don't have to learn the behavior
I just focus on learning the theta H now
how does theta H induce behavior so
again theta H corresponds to a utility
all that we really want to assume is
that people are gonna roughly be
optimizing this utility and I don't want
to assume anything else so the way I can
formalize this is I can search for a
policy that has maximum entropy so I
don't want to put any other inductive
bias into the system but subject to the
constraint that an expectation the value
according to theta H should be roughly
Epsilon optimal should be roughly should
be close to the optimal gap yeah
question over there in the previous
graphic seems to be that the human is
seeing the same state X as the robot -
and wondering why that is each human has
a different perspective that's right
that's absolutely right
so something that we're not going to get
at in this talk at all but something
that my group does work a little bit on
is this notion that we have different
knowledge and different really beliefs
about the world and even that the person
has that the person doesn't know
everything the robot knows especially
the robot the person doesn't know how
the robot works something that we play a
lot with is okay there's some parameters
that are actually on the human side
there's a theta R right that the human
thinks of as kind of hidden and now how
can the robot act in a way that is
informative about these parameters that
I hit into the person how can the robot
act to expose those parameters but we're
not going to talk about that today for
this talk we're going to assume that one
we know the physical state the other
thing we're going to assume for most of
this talk is that the robot actually
knows the dynamic both the robot and
human know the dynamics of the world
there's gonna be an exception to this
but for the most part we're gonna assume
that the fit dealing with the physical
world is solved why because it's that's
hard enough right so we don't want to
deal with that
and human so it's sort of a
divide-and-conquer but thank you for
that does really that's a really
important observation an assumption that
we're making here so where was I okay so
we take this notion we went from humans
have intent to there's the utility
function and now we try to turn that
into an actual behavior an actual policy
and if you solve this what you get is a
Boltzmann distribution where essentially
you expect the person to be taking
actions with the probability that it
gets exponentially higher when the human
in the one that action is closer to
optimal so that's the sort of noisy
rationale assuming that people are kind
of rational noisy reaction approximately
rational and though so this then leads
to you have a probability distribution
over what might happen next that now
your robot can actually use as its model
and again the trick is that we don't
learn all of that we don't learn the
whole policy we just learn data H and
the way we learn theta H is every time
the person acts so I stepped took the
step now this is an action that I took
the robot conveniently has this
probability distribution that tells it
how likely or unlikely that action is
for any candidate theta H so at least
mathematically computational or more
difficult but mathematically you can do
you can run Bayesian inference on this
you can do a Bayesian belief update to
update your distribution over what this
data each might be so and you can do
this online or you can do this offline
yeah yeah so clarification question
about that
so are we assuming that this behavior is
happening with the robot in the system
or and if so like do we have to worry
about the human also simultaneous that
question for four minutes or so maybe
okay thank you um so you can do this
offline you can collect a bunch of data
humans reaching our goals avoiding
obstacles etc and fit a model to that
and this is what we do with the
quadrotors so here's an overhead view on
the right we have the human and the
quadrotor they each
their goal and what you'll see is the
robot making predictions about what will
happen at the next time step there's
some low probability areas there's some
high probability areas and now the
quadrotor uses that to make sure it's
not in the way to make sure it avoids
collisions with the person here's
another example the person first goes
towards that goal and you see it's not
perfect right we because people are
noisy when they're actually walking
through the room and so it's not like we
get this perfect data but we can make
predictions about what's going to happen
next and make sure that the robot can
follow along now this is one example
what I really appreciate before I tell
you all the other thing that's wrong
with this and I complain a lot about how
it's all not right um let me only share
the things that I do like about this and
what we've been able to do based on it
so in this particular context we are
looking at the actual actions that
people were taking and treating them as
observations as evidence about their
underlying intentions and so basically
what we are saying is that roughly
speaking and this is not a harka strain
but roughly speaking the action that we
see the person take when it comes to
their actual ground truth utility that
should be a better action to take than
any other action that the person could
have taken which is why if you look at
this equation again it normalizes this
probabilities tribution normalizes over
the space of possible actions that the
person could have taken now what's nice
is that you can very easily generalize
instantiate the same formalism over a
plethora of other kinds of channels of
communication that the person could be
giving you for instance if a person says
doesn't give you a demonstration but
says gives your comparison says I
preferred this to that right well some
very similar thing you can do where you
can say well the probability of this is
still proportional to the exponent of
the q value of that action except that
now the person hasn't looked at all
possible actions and decided on the
correct one now the
person has looked at two options and
decided which one is better so we're
only going to normalize over those two
if the person gives you a correction
like I was doing to the robot when I
applied that external torque well it's
not that that itself is the right thing
to do but that's combined with what the
robot was doing that combined action is
something that we now know is good so we
can interpret it in the same framework
if the person tells you to stop
sometimes people say that they watch the
robot do something and they say stop
doing that you think there's not so much
information and that it's very small
signal but actually it tells you quite a
lot it tells you that stopping which I
denote here by you zero doing nothing
even that is better than whatever you
are actually doing and believe it or not
we've gone astray see as to also
integrate into this framework
observations of the kind an actual
reward function that a designer wrote
down engineered but only for some
particular set of situations we
interpret that as evidence about what
they actually want in general we look at
the current state of the world and we we
don't see an action we just see a state
but there's only some actions there's
only some reward functions that are
actually consistent to people having
acted in the world and having now that
state look the way it actually does
right so if an example I give you is you
look at the world and vases are not
cracked on the floor and you can infer
the chances are that people don't like
to run over vases just because they're
in the way they would actually avoid
them otherwise you'd see more vases
cracked on the floor and so there's a
lot of different channels of information
that you could look at and all of them
are evidence about what people actually
want either that what they want to do or
what they want the robot to do so this
is what helped us in this case as well
we're now I push in the same way and lo
and behold the robot takes it as
information about how I wanted to do the
task and that actually freakin stays
closer to the table just the simple wins
with these robots
and so I like this I like it because
it's almost the unified formalism for
actually accounting for different kinds
of behavior that you see in humans and
taking that in and getting robots to be
better at doing what we actually want
and getting for us to be better at
coordinating with us now the bad I had
some people we have some people play
lunar lander which is this Atari game um
you look at these and you know noise
irrational doesn't really come to mind
it's more noisy than rational the goal
is the land not crash land between the
two flags and people don't do a great
job at this and so this is kind of one
of the many examples where noise
irrationality is just wrong it's just
that that's not that's not how people
work so what's going on there um in
general I'd say that by going to nice
about noise rationality we go from a
very large space of policies to
considering a very small space of
policies so we go for something that's
perhaps too large to something that's
perhaps too small it's not flexible
enough it's too rigid and so with noise
irrationality would all the successes
we've been able to extract out of it I
felt a little closer to the truth but it
was clear that it wasn't the end of the
journey was more like the beginning and
what's really it you know a a way to
look at this is honestly that what we do
with noise irrationalities we take
people we get our special lens we stare
at them and squint through this lens
until they start looking a lot like
robots and we just treat people as if
they're robots left and right and that's
what my rationality is because if I take
this equation and I sort of flatten on
this slide what you have is reward
parameters go in the world has some
dynamics some transition function so
that goes in we plan that gives us a cue
function a Kia Optima q-value function
and then the only difference between
noise Russian army of robot is that for
a robot state goes in and you actually
do the art max take the optimal action
for a human we're saying okay they can
be a little bit noisy so we're
essentially squinting and treating the
pretending like the person is a robot
which does not seem quite right now what
I decided to do is lean into this so yes
it's a problem that that makes noise
irrationality to rigid the fact that
we're treating people as robots but
here's an interesting question what if
it's also the key to fixing it in other
words what if we thought about when
robots are not rational because the idea
is it's almost like a recipe for fixing
noise your rationality the idea is that
if there's there's ways in which robots
deviate from rationality it's probably
because being rational is a hard thing
to do and if it's hard for a robot it's
in some cases it might be hard for a
person to and let me share an example of
this so one way in which it becomes hard
for robots to be rational is that they
don't actually know the way the world
works
they don't have access beautifully to
this dynamics model and so if they don't
well they have to do it in Firstman
learning their actions are not gonna
look
noisy rational from according to this
definition when they're learning because
they're still gonna be learning so if
you look back at lunar lander and people
crashing all over the place here's an
overhead view of their trajectories um
red is failure doing this success and
then if you actually play with the
dynamics model with the way the world
works with the thrusters and the gravity
and so on all of a sudden their
trajectories start making a whole lot of
sense and so the hypothesis here was
that maybe noise irrationality makes
sense but maybe it's not for the correct
dynamics model because people don't
necessarily know how the world actually
works
maybe they are being noisy rational but
under a different model under some ADA
that we just don't have access to and so
naturally all we thought of doing is now
making that as part of our inference we
don't just infer their intent we also in
try to infer what it is that they're
assuming about how the world works it's
hard to do this jointly there's a lot of
ambiguity between the two and so what we
actually do in practice is we collect
these calibration tests where we
actually know what people are trying to
achieve or you can tell in hindsight and
then we fit dynamics parameters to death
and so far in this talk on I wrote down
Bayes rule and which is my favorite
thing to write down and sort of
pretended like we can just do this right
we just here's an observation model
Bayes rule it done mathematically makes
a lot of sense now let me tell you a
little bit of the dirty laundry it'd be
nice very nice to do beige pure Bayesian
inference we don't afford it very often
sometimes we do sampling what we did in
this particular case is we actually just
computed the maximum likelihood estimate
so what is the the dynamics parameters
that best explain the human actions and
even that is hard because to do this
optimization you have to differentiate
through the Q value function it's that's
challenging and so the next little bit
of dirty laundry was actually that we
came up with this algorithm where we put
the Q function itself as which was
representative as linear on that with
weights W as a variable that were doing
optimization over and our objective now
became twofold
it was about making the two sides of
this Q function consistent on the one
hand we wanted to find a Q function and
dynamics ADA that explained the
demonstrations right so that give high
probability so the Q function has to
explain you H on the other hand we
wanted to make sure that the Q function
is consistent with the left hand side
it's consistent with the dynamics and
with the reward and if there's an easy
way to do this
you just have to make sure that the cue
function has essentially achieved low
bellman residual over some sample states
so you look over sample states for the
cue what your cue function currently is
and what it would be if you did one
bellman update and that was it so now
what do we do with our inferred
parameters so we solved that
optimization problem and now we're
online the person is operating this
lunar lander and they're giving us some
control command view H now if we
actually execute H we saw what happens
people crash all over the place so this
takes us to some state through the
actual dynamics of the real world that
is an undesirable state a lot of the
time so we don't do that
what we do instead is we take you H and
we pass it through for dynamics
according to what we inferred is what
they how they think the world works so
this is essentially asking where does
the person think they're gonna go if we
execute you H that's the dynamics model
that we learned and so that's a nice
next date and then we invert through the
real dynamics we invert this this state
to get to the control that we need to
apply to get there and we apply that
control instead and it's not that it's
perfect but people don't fly all over
the place anymore and actually land the
thing when we do this
that was a struggle but eventually we
got there so um to land the aircraft
without assistance so they the
information you're providing back
doesn't help them learn how to land no
well we're not really providing in this
work at least we're not providing back
any information we're staying
so and we could and I don't know how to
do that right but it's a really
interesting question what we're doing
here is taking the input that they're
giving us and saying I'm not gonna
execute that I'm gonna try to execute an
input that leads the craft to this day
that you actually we think that you're
trying to send the craft to yeah so so
it's just they their experiences if we
get this right their experiences that
now they provide an input and the
aircraft actually goes through where
they think it will go right so if we get
this perfectly right that's the
experience that they have and you know
you can see that we don't get it
perfectly right but that it we end up
having a much more seamless experience
for them that enables them to actually
succeed at the task much more yeah avoid
fail states like in the last example it
comes very close to the ground outside
I'm like flipping over but eventually it
like recur X because this is like only
optimizing for the goal or is it also
saying like oh we shouldn't go like if I
go anymore left I'm gonna flip over and
crash good question it's not even
optimizing for the goal literally all
it's doing it's taking the human
controls which end up being whatever
they are at the point where you're
almost crashing and mapping that through
this you know forward dynamics learned
inverse dynamics of the real world yeah
and so of course you can you can do more
clever things here you can actually
start inferring the reward function
which is also something that we've done
and start actively assisting them right
so the notion here is that now I have no
longer noise irrationality but I have
this broader kind of rationality which
is there gonna be noise irrational but
not under the
real dynamics necessarily but under some
internal dynamics model that they have
so I allow people to sort of deviate
from noisy rationality and listen this
way and now I can actually do more
accurate rewards inference because I
have a more accurate model of how
they're producing their actions
conditioned on the state of the won yeah
it is for making an assumption about the
computational models being the same
between the humans and the machines
right because humans could also optimize
the reward function myopically and there
could be computational differences is it
also something that could be considered
in the future yeah so if so this was one
particular way in which robots are not
rational you sort of taken this recipe
and applied it in a bunch more ways
robots are also not rasher so it's when
they don't know the dynamics the myopic
thing is when they can't plan far enough
ahead so you can actually put their time
horizon as a parameter that you're doing
inference over and make that a little
bit more flexible sometimes robots need
to be risk-averse right so they don't
actually necessarily plan an expectation
they are risk-averse they plan under
some notion of worst-case or close to
worst-case an interesting one that we
looked at is humans are sometimes
suboptimal because they're actually
still learning what they want
so there's suboptimal with respect to
what they actually want because they
don't know it yet
right and so you have to account for the
exploration and the learning that
they're doing when you're actually
interpreting their action so so yeah to
answer your question we looked at more
than just the dynamics model and in fact
you know it's very it's in a sense it
sounds very silly because we're still
treating people as robots but we're
saying look there ways in which robots
have a hard time with this and we can
use some of those inside and bring them
in to actually make this more flexible
notion of inductive bias the flip side
is of course that sometimes people are
better than robots are so the flips
is to look at situations when people end
up outperforming rational robots and
here's what I mean by that here's a
situation where I have an autonomous car
in the middle lane and it needs to merge
into the left lane and there's all these
cars coming there's not a big enough gap
in traffic so a rational robot at least
according to this notions that we have
today and this comes back to a question
that one of you had about what if the
robot is acting in the world how does
that affect things so a rational robot
of today tends to make predictions about
how like much like our quadrotor but
then doesn't make predictions about how
these cars will move and make sure the
avoids collisions with them and so that
means that you either you can't actually
merge into the left lane so we either
keep going or stop and annoy a bunch of
people that's what the you know the
rational solution looks like and the
challenge here is that sometimes these
predictions are like self-fulfilling
prophecies you assume that people will
keep going you react to that and lo and
behold people keep going somehow by
magic people seem to figure this out
people magically create the space that
is not there and the reason they can do
that is because they actually reason
about the ways that he can influence
each other's actions and so with vanilla
noise rationality we're making
predictions about the person as if
they're acting in isolation but in
reality people are reasoning about the
robot two people are making predictions
about what the robot will do and that
the implication is very important the
implication is that the robots actions
end up influencing the actions that
people take and it's important for the
robot to reason about this in order to
actually navigate in human environments
and supposed to stay away from everyone
um it gets more complicated though it's
really Turtles all the way because
people also think about the fact that
the robot reasons about them and the
implication there is also important
which is that people know that their
actions influence the actions that the
robot is taking and so really this
mutual influence is really important so
let's think about this in the context of
self-driving cars the first part the
part that is about how robot actions
influence human actions that's what
enables the robot to know that if it
merges in front of the person the person
is likely to slow down because they can
see that coming and they want to also
avoid collisions so that's what that
gives us the second part what does the
second part gives us that the human
knows their actions influence the robots
what this gives us is now the robot
knows that in some cases it will try to
merge in front of the person and the
person might actually accelerate to get
the robot to go back to its lane and
this actually happens now you know not
all the time but it actually this is
something that robots have to also watch
out for if they go down the rabbit hole
of actually trying to change these
predictions not just taking them for
granted and so I have AI this is
actually real life because I have to
confess I live in San Francisco and it's
you know the plethora of autonomous
driving companies testing left and right
and so about once a month I say maybe
not more often but about once a month
I'll pull up at a four-way stop shortly
after an autonomous car and what I do is
I just go this is on video shoot what I
do is I go because I know that the car
will sit there and wait for me and so
this is something and you know I've
talked to the company and
thank me for the valuable data and we're
friends but this is something that you
can expect people to do so the bottom
line is that noise rash around the way
we've defined it doesn't quite hold
because really what we have is the robot
one agent with its utility the human
another agent with their own utility
that's how we formalized in 10 and the
two utilities don't have to be identical
they are when you have a human robot
team they're collaborating but when
you're sharing the road you each care
about your own goal your own efficiency
yes you have some common terms like you
care about avoiding each other but it's
not common pay off it's not zero-sum
either as general some so if we could
solve this game if we could solve it
just to get an idea I would look
something like this which start at the
end of the time horizon we would set the
values to zero for the human and the
robot would go back in time for every
date we'd look at all possible actions
that the robot could take for each
action that induces the probability
distribution using noise nationality of
what the human might do we can use this
now to update the robots Q value
function to figure out what the robots
optimal action is and update the robots
value function so the robot is deciding
what action to take such that when the
person responds that works out well and
then that then updates the humans value
function and then we do this for all
states and we propagate this all back in
time but I can't do this for real robots
right not in continuous state in action
spaces this is a no-go and so one thing
that we've been experimenting with is
this hierarchical decomposition we do
solve the game but we solve it add what
we call a strategic level where we
simplify state and action and dynamics
and we actually do this offline and
compute the values for the human and the
robot and then online we have a tactical
level that does model predictive control
continuous state inaction spaces but
uses the value from the strategic level
as a heuristic so that's been our more
success most successful approach so far
of all the
things that we've experimented with so
at the strategic level we do this crazy
thing but we do it for simplified state
action space the tactical level so the
vanilla version of what we do and I
simplified it here to be deterministic
just because the equations are nicer and
it's computationally cheaper so we would
be predicting a human trajectory um that
maximizes the human's utility and we'd
be giving that to the robot so that's
sort of the vanilla approach predict
what people want to do give that to the
robot have the robot optimize its own
utility using that prediction now the
tactical level were a little fancier
than that even there because we want to
capture the fact that the robot can
actually influence what the human is
doing and so we actually make youh a
function of you are we say the person
model the person is optimizing their
utility that the parents are their
trajectory but it also depends on what
the robot decides to do and now the
robot is facing this nested optimization
problem where it's wondering what should
I do such that when I expose the person
to that and they optimize their utility
that ends up working the best for me so
this is n we do model predictive control
here so we take a first step would we do
this
we solve this using we've experimented
with a few things maybe one of the most
successful one was a quasi Newton method
and the one trick here is that we also
add a terminal cost so we do this for a
short time horizon and then it's guided
by the values that we get from the
strategic level the thing that we solved
are fine so let me share a little bit of
what happens so this is by the way the
robots value that you see the robot
comes here and what it expects to happen
is that the person can actually move out
of the way so that the robot can
continue this is one interesting result
here now people don't always do this so
when they don't so this was someone a
human driving who didn't actually move
out of the way and what you see happen
here is that you'll see more and more
blue region there that attracts the
robot onto the right lane so that it
overtakes so we can deal with that too a
really nice example I found is this one
here the robot accelerates to try to get
in front of the person the person slows
down to make space here I'm gonna play
this again let me see
okay so here's the robot accelerating
here the robot goes the person
accelerates to deterred the robot and
then the robot has to slow down and go
behind and so I'm excited because we're
starting to see actual mutual influence
come out of this and robots that are
able not to just be there paralyzed but
are able to try to influence but also be
responsive to if it doesn't work it
doesn't work and I can do something else
and so we've taken again noisy
rationality and by thinking about where
people are to better than robots it's
really that the interaction is game
theoretic and people get that and so
we've broaden it to be now game
theoretic rationality and you know we've
done more and more things and it could
go on and on to this notion of very
flexible assumptions about rationality
where we still use the notion that
people have intent but we try to use
that in as flexible of a way as possible
before yes question situations like this
people also try to resolve the
uncertainty as much as possible fine and
a waving at each other is sort of making
eye contact and so on are you so with
robots it's kind of difficult to see how
they would do it but humans vice-versa
have you thought about I don't know
worrying that possibility again I just
have no idea how you would do it but
yeah it's an interesting question what I
stay away
from gestures because for me personally
in my research because they're highly
kind of cultural dependent change a lot
but what a lot of our work has been is
body language that emerges as a
consequence of formulating the problem
in the right way and optimizing for the
right thing and so we see so we see some
of these strategies like the ones that
we've just seen where the robot sort of
goes and expects the person to slow down
we've also had things emerge like a
robot inching forward at an intersection
to probe the person and see if the
person is slowing down and letting them
go or not right and so it's not that we
have reasoned explicitly about what the
person is inferring about the robot it's
just that we know that there are
different kinds of drivers out there and
we maintain a belief over what that is
and we take information-gathering
actions to resolve ambiguity and so that
results in non non gesture per se
communication but communication through
the actual physical actions that you can
take yeah so so this has been sort of
part of my journey I'd say to try to
push the boundaries of what we can do is
starting from this very simple starting
point ride people optimized for utility
going towards broadening god more and
more now one last aspect that I am very
excited about these days is the fact
that we're never gonna be exactly right
we're never gonna have this space that's
not super huge but somehow manages to
capture every human behavior that we
might encounter that's just that you
know it's it feels hopeless and so what
do you do then how do you make sure that
your robot still works in spite of that
in spite of completely having
misspecified
the space that you're actually doing
search over
and so here's an example
did you actually saw in the beginning
what we did here is we spilled some
coffee on the floor now Sylvia is
avoiding the coffee the robot model
Sylvia is noise irrational the robot has
no idea that there's coffee on the floor
that humans might care about avoiding
coffee that's filled on the floor and so
the robot so Sylvia is kind of deviating
but the robot very stubbornly believes
at every point that Sylvia will turn
around and start going straight towards
her goal because that that's a type of
autistic space right so what do you do
about that well what we'd like to do is
add the very least I don't know how to
fix this right I don't know how to
invent the concept of coffee at least
not without interaction from the person
so I don't know how to fix this but I
think at the very least we should be
able to detect that we have the wrong
space here right that to detect that we
can't actually explain what's going on
with the hypothesis space that we have
in other words I'd like for robots to be
aware that it is always gonna be a
potential reality gap between the model
and how the actual human works and so
I'd want the robot to be minding this
gap to be actively monitoring for this
so that at least it figures out that
something is going on that it doesn't
know about and that's been something
that's been really exciting for me
lately and it went back to this for the
first time in my life a story where some
some hack that we had that we had to
tune ended up being the thing that we
could actually do in a principled way
and it's the answer to this problem
so in noise rationale real quick I would
talk about this but we stick a parameter
beta in there it controls all ways we do
it because it captures our assumption
about how noisy House of optimal we
think the person will be if I said so
real quick of course for you if I said
beta equals zero what happens what am i
assuming about the person yeah we have a
uniform distribution right if I said
beta closer to infinity than I'm wanting
a person who is perfectly rational so
you know what do we do with you in this
beta we start with one
right and we make sure that the
inference kind of works well enough
that's what we that's what we do the key
thing here was to realize that this beta
not only can you actually make it part
of the inference so that you don't have
to tune it yourself but making it part
of the inferences what's gonna tell you
whether your misspecified or not because
basically as you actually allow the
robot to be doing inference not just
over the possible intents but also about
how rational essentially the person
appears for those intents you end up
being able to capture that you
essentially can't explain what is
happening you end up essentially you're
gonna fit a model the humans gonna
appear irrational right under all of the
hypotheses that you have the only way
you can get that probability
distribution to go up is by making data
close to zero and that should tell you
that you don't know what's going on
because if the person is very irrational
according to any hypothesis you have
then either the person is broken or the
model is broken right and so it's pretty
safe to assume in this day and age that
you don't have the right mom um that's
what we do right so here we're going
around or making predictions when a
person does something that we can't
explain
the robot is gonna use that as evidence
about beta beta is gonna go low and what
I really love about this is not only
that now we have a flag that says I
don't know what's going on but at the
next time step we don't have to do
anything special we don't have to if if
if statement did we don't have to switch
case it because just by using the
posterior that we have over beta which
now puts a lot of probability mass on
low betas what's gonna happen is we now
are going to have higher variance
predictions the robot is going to be
more uncertain about what's gonna happen
with the human in the next time steps
that's what happens when you have a
lower beta it results in these
distributions that look more and more
uniform
um so here it is in practice so if you
have if you fix beta to some high ish
thing which is what we usually do you
see this go on and the person goes to
one goal the person goes to another
going everything's fine but in a second
the person is gonna start going towards
a third unmodeled goal and the robot is
gonna think that any moment the person
is gonna turn around and go towards one
of the goals that it actually knows
about so that doesn't work the other
thing you could do is always keep a low
beta but then you're always very
confused about what the person will do
so that's not good either until buying
fern betta we're starting to get the
best of both worlds we're starting to
see that so here's the coffee example
we're pretty convinced now the Sylvia is
deviating and all of a sudden our
entropy increases here in our prediction
so now when she's starting to be aligned
to the goal again we start trusting the
model again with the goals - you go
towards one you go towards the other the
robot says ok this model makes sense the
moment Sylvia starts going towards the
next goal now this doesn't make any
sense anymore and the robot is confused
and here it is in real life I'm gonna
try to do this let's see
nope it doesn't work it's ok we can skip
that
um one worry of mine is what how to
handle multiple people this whole talk
has been about one robot in one person
in reality we have multiple robots and
multiple people and what's hard about
multiple people is that not only does
each of them interact with the robot but
they also interact with each other and
it's really kind of a start getting card
to capture all this complex interactions
mutual interactions and so one thing
that we can do is actually treat each
person as being independent when they're
actually independent everything is okay
when they actually start interacting
then beta is gonna go down we're gonna
was gonna realize that its predictions
don't make any sense they're not
consistent with what's actually
happening and it's gonna become more
uncertain about what what the people
will do in the next time step so here
are Jaime and Silvia and two little
quadrotors and they're moving along and
everything's fine but now they start
actually interacting robots get confused
that actual that quadrotor actually
paused and stayed behind and to allow
the situation to resolve so I like
seeing that and then finally when it
comes to pushes pushing on the robot so
when I push on the robot and my
Corrections actually is about something
that is in its hypothesis space I push
it closer to the table and actually
reasoning about distances to objects
like the table so it can actually make
sense of my correction what we see is
that it updates its estimate of what I
want it also estimates rationality which
you know like I'm saying only starts at
1 and goes up because it can actually
make sense of my correction when I push
it and I push it to correct it about
something that it doesn't actually know
how to reason about then what happens is
very quickly it realizes that it doesn't
know that it can't make sense of my
correction and what naturally what that
leads to is the robot tends to stick
more to its prior and not actually
update which is not doesn't I want to
just point out this does not actually
fix the model right this does not have
the robot magically figured out oh the
person must be avoiding the coffee oh
the person must be caring about this or
that I still don't know how to do that
but now what happens is that Lee at the
very least it enables the robot to know
that it doesn't know what's going on as
opposed to sort of blindly keep on
focusing on the hypothesis space that it
has okay so I've been asking myself what
the right inductive bias is when it
comes to human robot interaction to me
somehow we have to be using some form of
people have intent but
the exact right way to do that seems to
be tricky and to me it's been sort of a
two pronged approach on the one hand
take the models that we have and fix
them incorporate more and more
information so that they're better
they're they're more flexible on the
other hand make sure that we can still
do reasonable things when we're still
wrong where I'm where our assumptions
don't actually hope in general a lot of
this a lot of what I do is giving robots
these models of people as doing some
form of optimization or we didn't get a
chance to talk about it today but some
form of Bayesian inference about and
inferring Steve things about the world
inferring things about the robot and I
think those two tools have been at least
for me really useful not because they're
correct not because that's not that's
what's actually happening in people's
heads but because they seem to be useful
they seem to get us to have robots that
know how to coordinate with us they know
how to collaborate with us and get
better at doing what we want with low
sample complexity and with pretty good
robustness to things like covariate chip
so with that I'd like to thank you and
thank all of my students and faculty
collaborators that Brickley and we can
discuss some more thank you
[Applause]
what are your thoughts on I mean you
talked about making the human looked
like a robot but what about making you
know reversing that and making the robot
more like a human using these models to
say I want to restrict the space of
hypotheses for my policies so what if we
incentivize the robot with innocence be
closer to a human-like policy and it's
when it's searching for its own policy
yeah so I think that first of all that
that idea makes a lot of sense in
something like imitation learning right
where you collect a lot of data of how
people act and you don't want the robot
don't want to bother with oh there's
some objective function and then
optimize it but you just want to copy
the human behavior but in a way that
generalizes and so there you have the
same question of how can I actually
restrict my space of policies that I'm
searching over for myself to be so that
I would the same sort of issues like
distributional shoe so that's one answer
the other answer is in general I have
not been a proponent of making robots be
natural and just for the sake of having
them be natural a lot of the times you
see that these strategies emerge like
inching forward into an intersection or
nudging toward someone's lane and seeing
how they react and they're natural
looking strategies but they I think I
think it's important that they emerge
out of out of you know having formulated
the problem correctly being having a
good objective function on these
distribution of our objective functions
for the robot to optimize enabling the
robot to reason properly about people
and you know figure now what the right
thing to do is and if the right thing to
do is to act in a human-like way then
great
sometimes we found that that's not the
right thing to do so we have this crazy
example of a car that is actually polite
and cares about your efficiency not just
its efficiency and what it does at a
four-way stop is it
actually starts inching backwards in
inches backwards to get you to go faster
through the intersection and I kid you
not as crazy as it sounds in user
studies offences in simulation and a
driving simulator but we're real people
it actually works
people go faster through the
intersection it's a strategy that
actually I mean know what do you do what
do you have people behind and all of
that it gets more complicated but my
point is it's not something that humans
do but that doesn't mean it's not
something that we can interpret easily
and respond to in the way that the robot
intends
so I think for me that's the goal it's
to get the interaction right with
whatever tools it takes
if naturalness is part of that then I'm
very happy for natural laws to be there
the nested at the end you talk about how
the robots can determine when they're
when they have no idea what's been their
hypothesis seems to be incorrect
can the agents also reason about people
and whether someone so that's really
interesting I think that you can have
these different models of how people
might be responding to the robot and the
same trick applies if none of the models
seem to fit then you know that probably
you don't have it right yeah
clarification question on the the beta
learning just I'm trying to understand
there must be a prior or something else
because how else could I tell the
difference between beta being small but
the actual utilities were large because
the dopamine in my head gives me like 10
units of utility versus beta being large
but the actual scale of the utility
utilities are smaller and like nothing
in the behavior data that I collect
could ever tell these two explanations
about to come into a particular scale on
your utility functions and within that
you can actually start comparing
and you have a joint distribution over
beta and theta you know in practice what
we do is for instance we use linear
combinations of features and we use unit
degrees the unit sphere right so we use
unit norm vectors and then we don't have
that problem or we have I does discrete
theta is go one or go two and then we
don't experience that but yes in general
you have to be careful about this in a
sense it's a blessing and a curse of
this Boltzmann distribution right it's
what enables you to do things like and
for the level of rationality but it's
also a pain in the butt from the
perspective of actually being careful
about that scale yeah it's a good
observation yes to kind of related
questions on the example with the cars
merging where you said like humans do
better one question is they've been
things you're aware of where like the
robot like you have two robots
communicating with each other kind of
like like I have this model and you have
this model or I'm gonna anticipate like
or give you a heads up where where you
couldn't do that with necessarily a
human that's all like like in the back
end the other thing is with that model
like the ultimate goal a lot of times is
like oh I have to make an exit here and
I'm like late right and so like the
human doing that will make an init and
non intuitive move not because it wants
to merge but because it's like if it
doesn't merge it's not gonna get to the
end goals penny model those like second
second objectives where it's it's like I
need to make this happen because then
like if I don't make this happen the
next thing is that the like not knowing
enough into the future example you were
saying where the robots might not have
perfect information okay so for the
first one robot robot a lot of what
we've talked about can certainly be
applicable to situations where you have
robot robot but the there's no explicit
communication the advantage that we have
with robot robot is that in some cases
maybe we actually agree on a protocol
and we can actually coordinate
wirelessly in ways that we can't do that
with humans because we can't beam stuff
to their brains that said I don't want
to really claim I mean my focus our
focus in the lab has really been just
stick
to the our problem is coordinating with
humans which are these entities that we
don't have any kind of control explicit
control over it does apply to robot
robot in situations where you know
robots are actually doing things like
optimization but if they're running on
or RT or something like that and you try
to use our our cranks to make inferences
about what the other robot is doing it
doesn't work at all on your second
question I'm trying to parse out a
little bit so when it comes to
situations where I'm doing X because
that sets me in a good position to do Y
you're absolutely right that a challenge
with model predictive control when you
plan for short time horizons is that
you're not gonna you're gonna miss out
on those things it's even simpler than
that we couldn't get our robot to either
predict or do an overtake because it
never gets the you know the carrot at
the end which is oh I can actually get
back into my lane and and that's what's
one benefit of having this hierarchical
structure where we use the value we
actually solved the game and we use the
value as a heuristic is that that your
your even though at a simplified level
even though that simplified you can
still actually get a lot of information
about long term behavior strategic
behavior out of that so that's one
benefit the main benefit is that we
actually have which is a little subtle
point I didn't get a chance to talk
about is that we actually have the
correct information structure in the
game in other words at the tactical
level remember we were giving the human
access to the robots trajectory and so
that makes this assumption that's a
static stackelberg game instead of a
dynamic game it makes the assumption
that the person can just magically see
what the robot plans on doing and we'll
take that for granted and not try to
influence it but just do a best response
to that v so and we that's okay for the
tactical level the strategic level is
really nice to have to capture the
actual mutual influence and the fact
that people can magically see what the
robot plans to do and vice versa and so
that I think is the really
main benefit but a side benefit is
definitely that we can actually get
information about longer term yeah I
actually really found it inspiring to
think of humans as not just in depth
aware not just IC nationals but I'm
curious when when all our policies are
not explaining the human behavior data
all that well under these models I can
imagine maybe the black box policy
fitting approach maybe it's ending up
fitting things better but who knows
whether it's robust to Kovarian sure
some things that some curious about what
is the you can imagine very simple
things where you do this better
inference trick right and so you default
on your simple model but when you kind
when it's not doing a good job you then
go to your black box model you can
imagine more complicated things like
training a black box model in simulation
using the simple model as your simulator
so you can start doing the main
randomization you can start doing all
sorts of crazy things that are basically
treating noise irrationality or broader
noise rationale whatever it is as your
simulation essentially that you practice
in before you go after real-world and I
can help you with some domain
randomization perhaps actually avoid
things like covariant shift I don't know
oh all in progress or at least not even
in progress but more like in the plans
for someone to start working on the
summer is coming will have more time
how are these algorithms different from
something that would be used in
multi-agent systems that's the question
of robot robot person versus human robot
with robot robot a lot of times you have
explicit communication or you execute in
a decentralized way but you plan in a
centralized way with what humans were
just kind of stuck with whatever humans
are we can influence human behavior we
can make people adapt it takes some time
we have to familiarize them so that's
sort of the challenge of working with
the human setting as opposed to another
robot now that said you can imagine that
similar things couldn't be done on the
robot robot level if you have absolutely
no communication but it depends a lot on
what you can or can't assume about the
other robot yeah so we're doing a few
good give us a sense off but when you go
through these sort of increasingly
complex models of human behavior
complexities of the agent change because
you can't crank up a simulator so I'm
assuming you have to be particularly
careful about these things yeah so in
the days where we were just doing noise
irrationality over you know which of
these three goals is it those were great
days and we sort of scaled up to here
are a few features on the order of 10
and and then Bayesian inference stopped
working explicitly so we had to do
sampling or we had to do things like
maximum likelihood estimation and we had
to do it online which was really tricky
so more approximations were involved now
as we start adding in the time horizon
and the parameters of the dynamics and
all of that not only do we get into
sample complexity issues though nowhere
near just having a high capacity neuron
that policy so we're still babies
compared to that world but but we got
into
ample complexity issues the more
fundamental thing that we're getting
into is that that having a belief is
really important because there's
multiple possibilities explaining the
behavior that you see there's inherent
ambiguity between the reward function
and the dynamics there's inherent
ambiguity between the way and other
other kinds of biases that the person
has when they're actually doing the
planning what those are and the in an
extreme if you make that we've also
played with making that very flexible so
we've played with reward comes in
there's a neural net that does the
planning so something like value
iteration networks or something like
that and then we learned that we learned
the planner that the person is using
right just to see if that would ever be
feasible and and there you have to be
very careful about how you regularize
that what should prior you can actually
impose because you can take a reward and
have a perfect Maximizer you can have
the opposite reward and have a perfect
minimizer and they're gonna explain your
data just as well and if you need to
figure out if it's important for the
robot not to make predictions about the
person but to figure out what the person
wants so that it can help it's really
important to get the side of the reward
function correct so I think yeah priors
there end up being really important and
sample complexity is an issue and then
computation is also an issue and we're
starting to get more and more into that
and with you that when humans and robots
started interacting this communication
of intent is going to be sort of central
to having fruitful hair actions between
the two and I think we've seen that ways
to indicate intent such as like turn
signals on cars can be vastly helpful in
allowing humans to interact with each
other so I was curious about your
thoughts about whether we should be also
looking into maybe mechanisms like
lights or ways we can signal to the
robot what our intent is
so that the robot doesn't need to reason
about what we might be wanting to do
versus yeah so development to better
signals for communicating intent back
and forth between cuban robots yeah
absolutely I think that's a really
interesting and important area on the
very practical side I'll say that lights
and sounds and that kind of
communication can work really well if
it's depending on the particular thing
that you're trying to convey sometimes
we find that motion is very intuitive to
read into and does a better job
disambiguating sometimes we found that
motion is very confusing and needs to be
augmented by these other by these other
channels so on the practical side or
I'll say is it's very worthwhile to
invest in that and you just we just have
to make sure that the physical actions
themselves end up being consistent with
what it is that we're trying to
communicate with these other channels so
that's that's one thing on the sort of
less practical side I'll say that when
when we write out these sort of this
framework that I was talking about in
the beginning where we can take all
sorts of human behavior and interpret it
as evidence about what's going on I
think things like turn signals and so on
also fit into that story that what
whatever information people can provide
we've gone as far as if the person
writes down a reward function right so
it's very explicit sort of here have it
of course natural language plays a role
into this as well we just have to be
careful to not to interpret these things
in a flexible way because people say or
indicate things that they think they
want but they don't actually want and
and I don't you know and I think that
the key there is to have uncertainty and
flexibility over what's going on and be
able to make sort of follow-up queries
and be nuanced about where interpreting
the way we're interpreting these
behaviors so that for instance you know
if the person is still learning about
what they want
and they're sort of saying oh I want
this and that you can't really actually
trust this yet because they haven't been
exposed to all the different options for
them to actually realize what it is that
they care about so it says there's new
ones there too so that that's a much
more shil Asafa Cole have to be careful
about what people directly indicate
versus what it is that they actually
want
[Applause]